c'est un projet qui est au point mort
les 1800 logements du quartier gare des
cannes de la verrière
initialement prévue pour 2018 peine à
sortir de terre
la raison selon la municipalité le
blocage du projet par l'agglomération de
saint quentin en yvelines
on ne peut pas laisser en tout cas
sortir un projet comme ça qui ne
respecteraient pas ces normes de qualité
ces normes de dix prix village de la
demande d'aidé des verrières wattrelos
de toute façon au minimum c'est la
moitié c'est plus qualitatif c'est plus
pavillonnaire c'est pas en augmentant
comme cela la concentration la densité
urbaine magnifique que vous allez
améliorer la qualité selon la mère de la
verrière le projet ne démarre pas car le
président de saint quentin en yvelines
aurait pas encore désigné d'aménageur le
projet est validé il est dans le pays
lui 2
de l'agglomération il est dans le
contrat de développement de territoire
enfin on ne comprend pas pourquoi ça
bloque sinon une volonté politique de
monsieur fourgous et de quelques autres
de bloquer parce que à leurs yeux notre
notre projet zac ne correspond pas à ce
que voudrait mais on est chez nous dans
un communiqué l'ancien maire de la
verrière alain ajaj dénonce un diktat
inadmissible de la part de saint quentin
en yvelines
de son côté la mère de la verrière a
envoyé un courrier au préfet pour
demander à l'état de prendre en charge
le projet